remember joe biden came into office and
he made a tripartite promise he was not
going to shut down the economy he was
not going to shut down the country he
was going to stop the virus um all three
of those things are untrue so
this is going very poorly according to
cnbc.com today first-time filings for
unemployment benefits jumped last week
hitting the highest level in a month
according to the labor department
initial claims for the week ended
september 18th on a seasonally adjusted
basis totaled 351 000 an increase from
the previous week's upwardly revised 335
well ahead of the 320 000 dow jones
estimate the total was the highest since
the week of august 21st markets reacted
little to the news stock market futures
pointed to a strong opening safe haven
government bonds saw yields rise an
indication that investors were selling
fixed income as yields move opposite
price well the reason they are selling
fixed income right now is because of
inflation pressures you don't you don't
stay on fixed income when the government
is about to blow money into the economy
that's like the dumbest thing you can do
the inflationary pressures that are
being brought to bear by the federal
government right now
are long-term and they are systemic okay
we're not talking merely about
short-term price bikes we are talking
about the devaluation of the money you
have in the bank unless you go and you
put it in stocks which is why the stock
market continues to rise because people
are looking for a safe haven to put
their money right now
and meanwhile the democrats are enraged
enraged that republicans are standing up
to their big spending plans so when you
already have inflationary pressures
right when you already have the federal
reserve that has been tasked idiotically
with both full employment and monetary
stability okay this is something that
goes back decades the federal reserve
should have one job that is monetary
stability it should not be the job of
the federal reserve to ensure full
employment that is normally the job of a
legislature if you are going to be in
that sort of business having an
independent agency that is designed in
order to inflate or deflate the currency
in order to achieve full employment
essentially puts the federal reserve in
charge of all financial policy in the
united states to the detriment of people
who for example hold savings and live on
fixed incomes
all of this leads to inflationary
pressures that in the end bankrupt you
faster
because you recognize that if you keep
inflating the currency just to take a
quick example if you inflate the
currency year on year at a higher rate
if you keep pumping money into the
economy via federal reserve stimulus or
via legislative stimulus
then for example the fixed income
benefits of social security have to rise
in order to meet that
and if they don't rise then people start
saying where's all my money and if they
do rise who's gonna pay for that then
you need to take out more debt or you
need to increase taxes everybody knows
this is the case but politics is the art
of pushing off the inevitable in favor
of temporary expediency that is what
politics in the united states has become
perfect example of this is the
continuing debt ceiling debate so here's
the thing
the reason we keep hitting the debt
ceiling is because we keep taking out
debt that is the reason we hit a debt
ceiling
okay if you don't take out more debt you
don't hit the debt ceiling we are now at
like 29 trillion dollars in national
debt in the united states and we have to
service that national debt right we have
to pay people back because we borrowed
money from them we have to pay off on
the bonds we have to do all that sort of
stuff
that is incumbent upon us and if we
don't you have to take money from places
in the government where it's hit
in order to pay off that that
those debts right we have to take money
from for example social security or from
food stamps or from some of the programs
that are funded and we have to push it
over to the higher priority of paying
off all of the interest on the debt well
every so often we hit the debt ceiling
and parties both parties tend to be like
okay well we'll push it off until next
time we'll push it off until next time
well republicans right now are saying
we're not going to push it off until
next time and we're not going to push it
off until next time because we know the
minute we raise the debt ceiling you
immediately take out debt beyond the
debt ceiling
right this is the little game
if we keep expanding the credit line and
you keep blowing out the credit card
we're idiots to keep expanding the
credit line
so if you want us to raise the debt
ceiling you are going to have to pledge
to
actually come up with a plan to repay
the debt or you know not blow out
trillions of dollars in spent by the way
we do this with foreign countries all
the time right one of the chief
methodologies of the imf for years
really since the end of the soviet union
the the imf and the world bank
one of the things that they have been
doing since the 80s and 90s is when a
country is heavily in debt they say
listen
we are happy to give you a loan but you
have to show us how you're going to
restructure your economy so you don't
just keep taking out debt and spending
tons of money what the republicans are
saying to the democrats right now is
exactly that
and democrats of course are complaining
like why won't republicans go along with
this we of course have to raise the debt
ceiling it's irresponsible not to raise
the debt ceiling because then we can't
pay off our bills by taking out a second
credit card because that's essentially
what we're doing the debt ceiling is
taking out a second credit card
and republicans are like no you're gonna
have to come up with some sort of plan
to to pay this off and then we'll let
you take out a second credit card but
we're not gonna let you keep blowing out
the spending and take out the second
credit card and democrats are wildly
angry about this what if the risks that
people are feeling in the market have
very little to do with our unwillingness
to take out a second credit card and
more to do with the fact that we now
have a system that reinforces taking out
more and more and more debt without
making any sort of long-term plans for
repaying any of it and that eventually
reality will set in and that reality is
likely to set in sooner rather than
later if you regulate the economy at the
same time you're doing this if you want
to do debt led growth you have to let
business actually use that debt to
innovate you have to let businesses go
out there and make product you have to
let businesses go out there and invest
in new and creative ways but if you blow
out the debt
and all you do is pump money into
systems that are non-innovative in the
end demand will start to curtail demand
will fall off because you have not
created new cool products for people to
invest in and then you end up with
actual inflation you end up with
stagflation
anyway the democrats are fighting mad at
this it's irresponsible i love this it's
irresponsible not to take out the second
credit card because if we don't take out
the second credit card how are we gonna
pay off the first credit card here's joy
reid doing that routine
they're literally willing to destroy the
us economy just to own the limbs
republicans are refusing to vote to
increase the debt ceiling which could
have catastrophic results it is so bad
that six former treasury secretaries
wrote a letter imploring congress to
extend the limit saying that allowing an
unprecedented default could cause
serious economic harm
confronted with that reality republicans
say that of course the u.s can't default
on its loans but they refuse to help
democrats in any way
why should they help democrats in any
way democrats should be helping
republicans democrats are in the
majority all democrats have to do is say
we're not passing a 3.5 trillion dollar
budget along with this 1.2 trillion
dollar infrastructure package grand
total 4.7 trillion dollars inside a
month after a 1.9 trillion dollar
boondoggle that we passed back in
february
after spending seven trillion dollars
last year all they have to do is say
we're not doing that and they get their
debt ceiling increase
but they don't actually want to do that
right they just want to keep being
irresponsible here's don lemon pushing
the same idea it's the republicans who
are the bad guys weird because i noticed
who's in charge of the senate and the
house
is there any purpose to be in charge of
the senate in the house if you bear no
responsibility for the actual budget
bernie sanders says quote this is a slow
and torturous process when you have 50
people and no votes to spare
and going on to say that he thinks at
the end of the day that they're going to
work it out
that with a battle raging over what
should be a slam dunk and that is the
vote to raise the debt ceiling it should
be a slam dunk i should say it should be
a slam dunk it should be a moment of
bipartisan unity the treasury secretary
is warning of economic catastrophe and
anxious democrats are floating a plan b
raise a debt limit themselves on a
party-line vote
okay then they can just do that
they can they can raise the debt limit
themselves on a party line vote if they
really need to and if they really want
to or they could make a deal that's
bipartisan in nature like joe biden once
pledged to do what are the markets
seeking right now the markets are just
seeking stability and they're getting
none of it because of the bad covert
policy of this administration and the
bad regulatory policy of this
administration and the fact that this
administration is obviously obviously
attempting to curtail alternative forms
of investment so that you are forced to
basically buy us government bonds and do
things that the government wants you to
do
right the greater top down commands and
control priorities this administration
combined with their desire to spend
oodles of money is creating utter
turmoil in the markets which is why you
know what restored some level of
semblance to reality to this market so
the market dropped dramatically earlier
in the week why because of the talk
about the debt ceiling because of the
talk about the budget because of all of
that talk okay now the federal reserve
signaled that it is going to start
reversing its pandemic stimulus programs
in november and could raise interest
rates next year amid risks of a
lengthier than anticipated jump in
inflation
the response from the market is that
major u.s indices soared to intraday
highs following the central bank's
statement in other words the markets are
not looking for more loose money the
markets right now are looking for some
semblance of sanity and stability
meanwhile the administration is
providing none of it
the wall street journal reports that the
major u.s indices jumped literally
within minutes of the federal reserve
saying we are going to start tapering
off
all of this spending we're going to
start tapering off the qe
we're going to raise the interest rates
that is because everyone thinks the
government is being irresponsible but
democrats want to be irresponsible so
let's talk about democratic
irresponsibility for a second okay at
the same time that they're talking about
how we need to raise the debt ceiling
they're talking about basically
prohibiting banks from making
responsible decisions
in a little notice story joe biden is
now expected to name a cornell law
professor named
omarova
comptroller of the currency okay this is
a wall street regulatory position
which again all of this stuff is
patently unconstitutional all these
regulatory positions have nothing to do
with the original structure of the
constitution the administrative state is
a disaster area but
this particular pick should be shocking
to wall street
again the goal here of the
administration is command and control
top-down economics because joe biden who
is barely alive knows better than you
how to spend your money and knows better
than banks how to invest your money
according to the wall street journal
president biden plans to nominate a law
professor who has criticized wall street
banks to oversee some of the largest u.s
lenders
biden is expected to tap saul umarova a
cornell university law professor to
become comptroller of the currency which
oversees national banks like jp morgan
chase and bank of america
the occ is an independent bureau of the
treasury department and oversees about
1200 banks with total assets of 14
trillion dollars that's two-thirds of
the total in the u.s banking system it
makes it one of the most powerful
regulators alongside the fed and the
federal deposit insurance corporation
the powerful comptroller of the currency
has a seat on the board of the fdic as
well as on the financial stability
oversight council a panel of senior
regulators charged with detecting risks
to the financial system
so what does omarova actually want to do
well first of all she's a woman and as
we know that's the important thing
even though women don't exist i mean
we've been told that men can be women
in fact
as we'll discuss in a moment uh the wilk
have now suggested that even if you are
to say a woman in a quote like an old
quote will now remove it but she it's
very important that she is a
self-identified woman because she's the
first full-time comptroller to run the 3
500 strong agency since abraham lincoln
signed it into law in 1863.
she would likely work to help fulfill mr
biden's campaign push to expand access
to banking services in underserved
communities as part of that effort
should help lend a planned overhaul of
the rules for the community reinvestment
act a decades-old law governing hundreds
of billions of dollars in lending and
investment in low-income areas
and now you might remember the community
reinvestment act the community
reinvestment act was one of the vehicles
that was used to create the 2008 real
estate bubble because the community
reinvestment act was basically the
notion that we had to push banks and to
push private entities or public private
entities like fannie mae freddie mac
into giving loans
at non-repayable rates to people who are
likely to default
she is now going to be in charge of this
okay what's some of the stuff that she's
talked about well on twitter she
criticized this summer's end to
temporary restrictions on big bank share
buybacks and dividends after the banks
performed well in annual stress tests so
she says banks should not be allowed to
buy back their stock and said we should
just have diluted prices for the stock
in a separate tweet she criticized a
news report on acquisitions by jp morgan
quote does the world need jp morgan to
grow bigger or more powerful just
wondering
well i mean the question isn't should
they grow bigger or more powerful the
question is what right do you have to
stop them from making economically
feasible decisions
omarova has called for a shift of
consumer banking deposits from private
firms to the federal reserve she calls
to effectively end banking as we know it
so what you would like is for you not to
deposit your money at a bank
which by the way creates the economic
system that we have because if you
deposit money in a bank your money
doesn't sit in the bank the bank then
lends out the money at an interest rate
to other people who then take that money
and create new products and services if
you leave it with the federal deposit
insurance corporation for example
or the federal reserve you think the
federal government is going to give out
loans on the basis of loans that are
likely to be repaid bank of america has
an interest in its loans being repaid
does the federal government have any
interest in its loans being repaid
of course not they can just tax you to
fill in the gap then you just take out
more bonds
her 2020 paper endorsed steps to quote
radically redefine the role of a central
bank as the ultimate public platform for
generating modulating and allocating
financial resources in a democratic
economy the people's ledger
the so we're going to turn
the federal reserve into
not just the central bank of the united
states we are going to turn it into
apparently the only bank in the united
states controlled by the federal
government you don't see any sort of
risk to this you don't see why perhaps
wall street is a little shook by this
administration
a republican senate aide said gop
lawmakers are concerned her views are
quote far to the left of anyone we've
seen in the regulatory space
well yeah they are
meanwhile in other news that is likely
to upset investors the federal reserve
is looking into launching a digital
currency now having a digital currency
on its own is not that bad an idea
right digital currencies i'm a big
proponent of bitcoin i'm a big proponent
of ethereum i own some of both
the the idea of a digital currency which
cuts out all of the sort of middlemen
that that exist when you do a financial
transaction and they're all sort of like
seven eight institutions every time you
swipe your credit card there are seven
or eight institutions in the middle
before the payment is actually verified
right having a a fed coin for example
that is pegged to the price of something
to the to the price of the dollar makes
some sense but the problem with creating
a federal reserve currency is that what
you are eventually going to get is the
federal reserve actually controlling how
you spend your dollars if the federal
reserve is where you hold your dollars
right a digital currency
so right now if you own bitcoin you own
it in a place like coinbase right you
have a digital wallet the digital wallet
holds the currency okay if you have a
fed coin like a digital u.s currency it
is going to be held by the federal
reserve presumably digitally what if the
federal reserve decides that it is going
to place a negative interest rate on
your savings
but it's going to spur you to spend by
creating a negative interest rate
charging you to hold your money in the
federal reserve system and then making
it nearly impossible for you to take
that money out and invest it in an
alternative form of currency like
bitcoin that's precisely what it seems
like the federal government is now
intent on doing
also
do you really think it should be easier
for the federal reserve to distribute
money it is very likely the federal
reserve instead of having to inflate the
currency by buying bonds what if they
just add a few zeros to the ledger and
they just directly deposit all of the
money and what if they just do that
we'll just make we'll give them even
more power
according to cnbc the federal reserve is
pushing ahead with its study into
whether to implement its own digital
currency we'll be releasing a paper on
the issue shortly
no decision has been made on the matter
as of yet the fed does not feel
pressured to do something quickly as
other nations move forward with their
own projects
and now again there could be a fed coin
or there could be a financial
a financial security infrastructure set
up by the united states that facilitates
the use of alternative cryptocurrencies
but that's not what this is likely to be
this is likely to be a chinese style fed
coin in which they can inflate and
deflate the currency
jog you to spend or jog you to save by
central policy
pell said the fed is working proactively
to evaluate whether to issue a central
bank
digital currency and if so in what form
establishing a digital dollar has been
on the fed's radar for more than a year
and announced in may would launch a
deeper examination into the issue with a
paper to follow
advocates say central banks digital
currencies the benefits include getting
payments quickly to people in times of
crisis also providing services to the
unbanked right the fact is that there
are a lot of people in poor areas who
can't get a bank account because
number one they live far from a bank or
number two they're bad credit risk so
the bank doesn't want to extend them
credit for example or it costs an
overhead charge in order to open a bank
account they can't afford it so they're
just unbanked right a lot of people this
is why people go to payday lenders for
example okay so that that's actually a
good service it makes sense this is all
the services of bitcoin but brought to
you by the federal government the
problem is when they start manipulating
the currency which is probably what they
will do pell says we think it's really
important the central bank maintain a
stable currency and payment system for
the public's benefit that's one of our
jobs
the test for any form of digital
currency put out by central bank is
quote are there clear and tangible
benefits that outweigh any costs and
risks
okay some concerns have been raised that
if the fed does not act more
aggressively the dollar's position as
the global reserve currency could be
challenged but again what most people on
the sort of libertarian rights who are
big into bitcoin are worried about is
not
that the us is going to be out competed
by by china on this although that is a
concern what they are more worried about
is the federal reserve taking over all
of the auspices of decentralized banking
by re-centralizing banking and this is
why
i would be far less concerned about a
fed coin
if they were not simultaneously looking
to heavily regulate crypto right they're
seeking to cut off all alternative
avenues of investment
according to the
according to bloomberg news today quote
cryptocurrency firms are fighting for
lobbyists and fielding subpoenas in what
could be an existential fight over how
the multi-trillion dollar industry
should be regulated so in other words
what cryptocurrencies basically are is
they are a way of you diversifying
against the interests of government that
is basically what cryptocurrencies have
become bitcoin has risen in prices
people have become less sanguine about
the prospects of central governments
actually repaying their debts just like
gold and silver it's a digital form it's
a store of value for a lot of people
secondarily crypto can be used as an
actual currency el salvador recently
said that you can use crypto as a
currency it has yet to gain a full scale
foothold in the united states for use as
an actual currency with its own value
and it's still dollar denominated in a
lot of places with all of that said the
notion that you're going to regulate
bitcoin so that it is now a security as
opposed to for example a currency or a
commodity is really dangerous if the
federal government can regulate
alternative forms of currency out of
existence regulate alternative forms of
commodities out of existence because
they're afraid you're going to invest
your money in bitcoin as opposed to the
fed coin
well that just leads to more centralized
power more centralized power is
precisely the opposite of what people
were seeking to achieve with digital
currencies in the first place
according to bloomberg over the last
decade the cryptocurrency market has
grown from a little-known project shared
among technologists and libertarians to
a massive largely unregulated sector but
even as the sector has found innovative
ways to record ownership digitally and
transfer money cheaply right that's what
blockchain does the idea is that
blockchain makes it secure to transfer
your money because we can verify every
single transaction
it's also launched savings accounts and
investment funds products regulators say
ought to follow the same rules as those
of traditional financial networks and of
course the senate of the united states
basically tried to kill crypto just a
couple of weeks ago when they
in this 1.2 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill they refused any
edits that would have exempted bitcoin
miners from regulations targeting
securities traders
right all of this is dangerous there's a
reason for the for example that china
has been targeting bitcoin right china
has been basically locking down bitcoin
and stopping crypto mining because
they're afraid that people are going to
start moving their money away from
chinese currency and into bitcoin
so what you're seeing from the bite
administration is heavier regulation
shut down the alternative avenues of
investment and we'll maximize the amount
of control that the federal reserve has
over your dollar and maybe
through new regulatory infrastructure
and maybe through new regulatory
appointments will put in place people
who basically shut down the ability of
banks to invest properly and then you
wonder why the economy is slowing
because you've created systemic
obstacles to the growth of the economy
and at the same time you're doing that
you're still locking down the country
over covid where you're still doing the
coveted paranoia routine
it it is amazing every few days i just i
wonder to myself why are we still doing
this when i say this i mean once you're
vaccinated you're good to go and people
have lost their absolute ever-loving
damn minds they've lost their minds
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content